Just finding it, and how's that?
Yes, that's perfect, dude.
Just stay right there.
This is boring.
Elana, you're the one that
wanted me to draw your portrait.
What did you think
this was going to be like?
I don't know. I thought it might
be a little fun.
Okay, well just hold it still.
Okay, okay, okay.
There we go.
Are my nipples hard?
Are you capturing that?
It's hard with overalls, but ...
Elana, seriously?
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Gotta move my body, girl.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yowza. Okay, here we go.
Elana, have you
ever heard of continuity?
Am I supposed to be
naked for this?
The answer now and forever
is no, you should not be naked.
Elana, for fuck's sake.
Sit still.
Okay, listen you watch
your tone of delivery, bitch.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm done.
Okay. I'm so excited to see it.
Okay, I hope you like it, dude.
Aw, am I tied up?
It's aspirational.
For my nipples, too. Thank you.
I love it.